I do a freestyle rap that's improvised
made up on the spot based entirely on
your suggestions it's not written
prepared or rehearsed so therefore you
everyone in this room needs to start
thinking of a word a topic or a phrase
you'd like a rap about we'll get five
suggestions that will drop a beat if you
are sat in this rectangular segment here
run into the wall would you like a rap
about
Will Smith um what specifically about
him and don't say the thing that you're
thinking of
come on there's more to that man than
just being a massive [ __ ]
Men In Black okay Will Smith in Men In
Black cool thank you very much and then
you've gone over here yeah what's your
wrap up
the Confederate flag the Confederate
flag
no no no no no because no no no no
because you no you can say it right she
said I mean she's not I haven't asked
what what color underwear are you
wearing are you have you got the South
will rise again just over there what's
what's specifically about it
oh the underwear okay out of context sir
that was really weird
[Laughter]
let me ask you what what what state are
you from I mean we can tell what state
you're in because South Carolina oh [ __ ]
okay well we know their opinions on it
Men In Black and Will Smith the
Confederate flag blame them for that bit
middle of the room what do you guys like
a rap about yes
star signs what is your star sign
Leo what does that mean
it means that you make friends really
easily just just like yes did you just
you're doing this
this is I lived in La for four years and
this is the type of [ __ ] they did over
there you're a Leo oh my God amazing
okay Leo star signs I know nothing about
them this corner over here so far it's
kind of a mixed bag you're ready to
shout out worry about the show
hip dysplasia amazing okay cool did you
suffer from hip dysplasia unlikely
because you are a male and usually it
affects females the firstborn especially
if breech birth yeah I [ __ ] paid
attention
foreign
be [ __ ] sick it's just gonna be an
information download and then I'll just
rhyme Confederate flag and move on from
that bit this section over here what do
you want to rap about
oh they win their case there were two so
you said Venetian glassblown have you
been to Murano
it's the island where they do the
Venetian Cafe sorry look look
I like when I said oh maybe you went to
Oxford I [ __ ] did right I just dress
it down
press it down and wear a hood
okay Venetian glass blowing Confederate
flag Men In Black and Will Smith hip
dysplasia
um and then the other the other one
remind us
star signs Leos of course [ __ ] you're
still rowing and then there was another
one in the corner what was it
what
as oh oh because he's being crazy and
okay we'll start with that but yeah okay
can we can we turn that beat up over
there there we go we'll we'll deal with
Kanye briefly and then we'll move on to
the rest of it let's do this nice
we drop it in town Lots when I hit pop
man going crazy interview on this Fox
News Channel speaking to Tucker I'm like
back in the day he had the luck with all
of the albums whole Nations loving The
College Dropout and graduation even
you've got the ones coming after Twisted
nightmare but now it's a PR disaster
Kanye's people are like [ __ ] I can't
believe you saw anti-semitic you've got
a maybe go and see a therapist I have a
daughter's got a problem with the hips
but we fixed it yeah you know I'm
addicted I know in relation there's more
sick kids she came out and they were
like this is very common mild dysplasia
of the hips if you don't understand
don't get my point it means it's not
firmly the socket and the joint entwined
big hit yes yes I tell this the socket
doesn't insert to the pelvis sole you've
got to make sure it's harmless and wear
a thing called a Pavlik harness it makes
the legs go up like a frog someone over
there is like he's doing the job really
well okay I'm taking the back when Will
Smith did the slap but Men In Black
slapped I love that movie I loved his
rap too I was like [ __ ] I wanna ask you
will can I be your Tommy Lee Jones meet
you and me little red line on your own
take the car with the button that makes
it go faster the guy with the head that
asks can it grow back yes it does that's
the first one I've never seen the
sequels unlike aversion to any of that
let me ask this you just clapping over
here you can ask Chris do you need a
beat in your show I'd be like no you say
I'm a Leo I look at this zodiac signs do
it with Precision I can clap why I've
got very good Rhythm oh yes you know the
Leos provides they're a group of lions
so you know they take right that's a
lion pun you didn't even get it that's
okay the star sign's not perfect you can
make friends you could be Chums like we
can go out on Leo best friend runs
running over here jogging through the
park this section of the rap's gonna get
pretty dark like your underwear
on the table said it's just black ah
[ __ ] It's kind of awkward we see over
there South Carolina tihi the daughters
of the Confederacy were putting statues
everywhere so people could see saying
nah it's kind of weird to say this
people say the Confederate flag is
racist but I don't think it is that's
some opinions if you actually have that
a real silly one it clearly is it was
the symbol of the South if you like
it'll rise again then hush your mouth
got the red the white with the blue and
the stars I don't like that oh yes we
know we really are having such fun the
last thing that we'll do remind me sir
what we got from you of course not the
man it was the lady who said I want to
go to Italy get out of bed look out my
windows see the beautiful canals all of
the Craftsmen The Artisans dwell over
there what do they do they're really top
class they get a long pipe start blowing
all the glass turning it around that is
how they learn take care cause it's
sticky it can hurt when it burns they
make a beautiful sphere make a lovely
Globe they sell it make a lot of cash
all over the world Murano that's the
name of the island I dropped it people
were clapping their hands like he knows
the name of a City Glass so pretty used
to think that knowledge that he would
have would have British shitty now we go
that's a wrap make it hot make it hippie
ending with the Venetian glass that's a
little B
itch
yeah